au régime selon lui de l' escalade dans
l'est de l'ukraine le président russe a
échangé avec emmanuel macron par
téléphone à les deux dirigeants ont
convenu de tout faire pour aboutir
rapidement cessez-le-feu dans le donbass
cessez le feu immédiat qu'exige le
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky
[Musique]
elle 190 personnes interpellé une
cinquantaine de véhicules remorqués la
police canadienne reprend le contrôle
d'ottawa la capitale fédérale paralysé
pendant 24 jours par des manifestants du
convoi la liberté des camionneurs au
départ qui s'opposent à la politique
sanitaire du gouvernement
[Musique]
actualité de la semaine marquée par
l'annoncé du retrait du mali de la force
barkan sens de l'opération des soldats
français est précipitée par la
dégradation des relations entre paris et
les militaires au pouvoir en départ
célébré hier par des manifestants à
bamako à l'appel de mouvements de
soutien aux autorités de transition
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
a les efforts diplomatiques
s'intensifient pour trouver une issue à
la crise ukrainienne avant un échange
avec le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky emmanuel macron elle s'est
entretenue par téléphone avec vladimir
poutine
le président russe qui dénonce des
provocations ukrainienne selon lui à
l'origine de l'escaladé dans l'est du
pays il insiste sur la mise en oeuvre
des accords de minsk ensemble les deux
dirigeants plaident la voie diplomatique
pour résoudre la crise la correspondance
à moscou de vera goffman une nouvelle
conversation téléphonique entre
emmanuelle maccoyii vladimir poutine
après leur entrevue au kremlin le 7
février dernier les deux chefs d'état se
sont mis d'accord pour organiser une
réunion du groupe de travail afin de
parvenir à un cessez-le-feu dans le
donbass selon le communiqué du kremlin
le président russe a exprimé une vive
préoccupation au sujet de la grave
détérioration le long de la ligne de
contact dans le donbass pour vladimir
poutine cette escalade est due aux
provocations des forces de l'ordre
ukrainiennes le président russe a
également attiré l'attention de son
homologue français sur les livraisons
d'armements et de munitions moderne à
l'ukraine effectué par les pays de
l'otan je propose d'écouter il est à
nouveau souligné que kiev ne fait que
stimuler le processus de négociation et
refuse obstinément la mise en oeuvre des
accords de misc et des accords conclus
dans le cadre du format normandie compte
tenu de l'urgence de la situation les
présidents reconnu qu'il était opportun
d'intensifier la recherche de solution
par des moyens diplomatiques au niveau
des ministères des affaires étrangères
et des conseillers politiques des
dirigeants des pays membres du format
normandie ces contacts vise à contribuer
au rétablissement du cessez-le-feu et à
faire progresser le règlement du conflit
autour du dombass selon l'elysée les
deux présidents se sont accordés sur la
nécessité de privilégier une solution
diplomatique à la crise actuelle est de
tout faire pour y parvenir elle a été
convenu toujours selon l'elysée que le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian
rencontrera son homologue heureux sergey
lavrov dans les prochains jours quant à
la partie russe on ne confirme pour
l'instant qu'une conversation
téléphonique entre les deux chefs de la
diplomatie demain le 21 février le
président français s'est également
entretenu avec son homologue ukrainien
wladimir zelensky hier et ce dimanche
après sa conversation avec le président
russe selon l'elysée le président
ukrainien confirmé son souhait de ne pas
réagir aux provocations et de respecter
le cessez le feu et les échanges vont se
poursuivre emmanuel macron doit
s'entretenir avec son homologue
américain et le chancelier allemand dans
les prochaines heures avant une réunion
extraordinaire de loi c e demain
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe la diplomatie
s'active donc le regard à des manuels
dupuy président de l'institut de
prospective et sécurité en europe la
présidence française a évoqué même
possiblement une rencontre avec le
président à lumière poutine les le
président et nice qui voire même un
dialogue avec le président joe biden
alors ce n'est pas une avancée du rythme
française puisque sergei lavrov et
anthony blinken ont prévu de se réunir
jeudi prochain année au moins la
diplomatie suisse en courant le dialogue
ne se fait pas seulement entre l'otan et
l'union et la russie cela étant
évidemment la présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne doit tenir
compte du fait que ce dialogue se fait
sous l'égide de louis xi e tout le monde
est en train d'être particulièrement
actif pour obtenir la réunion tripartite
le groupe de travail tripartite que vous
mentionnez mais surtout pour qu'il y ait
la tenue très prochainement d'une
conférence en format normandie qui
verrait le président et minsk et le
présent byden le président poutine et le
président mêmes macro il faut aussi
avoir à l'esprit que 73% discret bien ne
reconnaissent pas de légitimité au
protocole de minsk et aux formes en
normandie c'est sans doute une des
raisons pour laquelle il ne s'est pas
tenue ou ne s'est pas réuni depuis
décembre 2019 et sur le terrain dans le
donbass les deux parties s'accusent de
la recrudescence du conflit d'un côté
les forces du craignent haine de l'autre
les rebelles des républiques
autoproclamées de donetsk est lougansk
conflit qui dure depuis 2014 mais la
tension est montée d'un cran ce week-end
allez violation de cessez le feu se sont
multipliées
redoutant une offensive de kiev les
rebelles ont décrété la mobilisation
générale est appelée à l'évacuation des
civils on retrouve dans le donbass notre
envoyé spécial antoine claireaux
nous sommes à gorzow cannes ville dont
on a beaucoup entendu parler tout au
long de ce conflit que ce soit au début
à l'été 2014 ou encore début 2015 et
même en 2018 la ville a été le théâtre
de furieux combats entre les forces du
craignait et la milice de la république
autoproclamée de données c'est donc pour
cette raison qu ici plus qu'ailleurs les
gens sont disposés à répondre
positivement à l'appel à évacuer lancé
par denise boucher line le président de
cette république populaire de deux
nièces qu donc résultat plusieurs
dizaines d'autobus qui sont allés
auparavant chercher les gens dans les
campagnes viennent donc les déposer ici
en garde goal of kai d'ici quelques
quelques minutes un train va les amener
jusqu'à la frontière russe pas moins de
500 personnes sont attendues à bord de
ce train il ya donc l'évacuation d'un
côté et la mobilisation générale de
l'autre tous les hommes âgés de 18 à 50
50 sont attendus pour servir sous les
drapeaux pour défendre la patrie du
dombass et tous les moyens sont bons
pour les attirer des messages sur les
réseaux sociaux ou encore par sms tous
les téléphones qui reçoivent le signal
de cette république populaire de données
est ce qu ont reçu ces messages appelant
à défendre le dombass et femmes enfants
et personnes âgées sont évoqués évacués
du dombass vers la région voisine russes
de rostov des arrivées massives l'état
d'urgence a donc été déclaré dans
plusieurs villes frontalières des
personnes évacuées et accueillies
notamment dans une école sportive de
taganrog le temps que des trains soit
affrété pour les conduire dans d'autres
régions de russie où elles seront logés
reportage de malice d'estrées
nous trouvons actuellement dans une
école sportive de tag and rock dans la
région de rostov suite à l'état
d'urgence décrété hier dans la région l'
école à cesser la plupart de ses
activités sportives pour accueillir des
personnes évacuées du donbass ici celles
ci peuvent manger des repas chauds
recevoir une aide médicale ou encore des
produits hygiéniques
de l'alimentation pour enfants est
également se maintenir au chaud le temps
qu'un train puisse les amener dans une
autre région russe où elles pourront
être logés
[Musique]
376 personnes sont passées par nous
elles se sont enregistrés ont reçu des
côtes à la sberbank pour recevoir la
prestation de dix mille roubles
si n'avez
pas encore de 10 heures à 11 heures
elles ont eu le petit déjeuner des repas
chauds elles se sont reposées
il y avait des lits et de la literie et
maintenant elle se dirige vers la garde
[Musique]
bonne chance à lui
les gens ici sont très gentils ils nous
aident ils peuvent nous renseigner sans
problème on nous accueille très bien
vous avez des proches qui sont restés là
bas dans le don bas siffler oui mon mari
mon fils mes filles et mon petit fils
aussi ils hésitent il regarde comment je
m'en sors ici ils réfléchissent ne
savent pas s'il faut partir ou pas ça
dépend de la situation
quelle est la situation là bas qu'est ce
qu'ils disent il y à des bombardements
tous les jours des attaques depuis les
banlieues et partout on craint que les
événements dès 2014 ne se reproduise car
vous voyez la situation
les personnes que vous voyez derrière
moi attendent le bus qui les conduira à
la gare ce n'est pas la première fois
que cette école aident les réfugiés elle
l'avait déjà fait en 2014 au début de la
guerre du donbass mais cette fois ci des
mesures sanitaires supplémentaires sont
prises compte tenu de la situation
épidémiologique toujours tendu jusqu'à
présent aucun des réfugiés enregistrés
ici n'avait de la fièvre ils ne
présentaient d'autres symptômes du cog
hill
le calme semble être revenu à ottawa la
police canadienne a quasiment repris le
contrôle du centre de la capitale
fédérale paralysé pendant 24 jours face
à face tendus ces dernières heures entre
manifestants et convoi de la liberté et
forces de l'ordre la police qui a
procédé à l'arrestation de son 90
manifestants et remorques une
cinquantaine de véhicules les autorités
avaient haussé le ton au début du
week-end estimant qu'il était temps pour
les camionneurs de partir au qui
protestent contre la politique sanitaire
du gouvernement une opération policière
est toujours en cours
aujourd'hui nous avons fait des progrès
significatifs pour retirer en toute
sécurité cette manifestation illégale de
nos rues à chaque étape de cette
opération nous avons été franc et clair
avec les manifestants illégaux pour leur
dire qu'ils devaient quitter les lieux
nous les avons informés de nos efforts
de maintien de l'ordre afin qu'ils
puissent continuer à prendre des
décisions en connaissance de cause je
m'appuie cet avertissement par une
opération délibéré méthodique utilise
dans des tactiques légal est sûr et
certains manifestants ont assuré qu'il
continuerait à faire pression pour une
levée totale des restrictions antico
vide dans le pays certains promettant de
revenir
je suis ici depuis 20 jours et ils sont
très agressifs aujourd'hui pousse en
arrière c'est extrême ce n'est pas le
canada les gars c'est une dictature
trudeau ruine notre pays venez ici une
ayez pas peur soyez aux côtés de ce
genre
ce chapitre se termine mais je pense que
le message est passé dans beaucoup de
coeur nous prendrons du rampeau
maintenant et puis dans quelques
semaines nous nous réunirons quand il
fera plus chaud quand ce ne sera pas
aussi dure et plus de jours nous
rejoindront on va se réunir on ne fait
que planter les graines
en france aussi ont manifesté hier
contre les restrictions sanitaires la
france où côté épidémies les indicateurs
sont rassurants l'espoir d'une
amélioration dans les hôpitaux certains
établissements avaient en effet activé
le plan blanc dispositif d'urgence pour
faire face à la crise sanitaire mais
l'amélioration de la situation
annonce-t-elle pour autant un retour à
la normale dans les hôpitaux éléments de
réponse à laquelle n masculine
la situation épidémique s'améliore ces
dernières semaines le nombre de patients
qu'ovide diminue mais pour le
gouvernement il faut encore attendre
pour lever le pass vaccinale
le choix de l'animal ce n'est pas un
choix qui se fait au hasard il repose
sur le principe selon lequel plus aucun
hôpital n'est obligé de déprogrammer des
soins à cause du coc vide ce qui n'est
pas encore le cas
selon l'agencé régionale de la santé 13%
des activités médicales 14% pour les
opérations chirurgicales ont été
reportées dans les hôpitaux sur la
période du 4 au 11 février
selon un rapport de l'ap-hp 74% des
salles fermées dans les hôpitaux de
paris la semaine du 24 janvier l'était
en raison d'un manque de personnel et
non pas du coc vite 19
selon l'ap-hp
18% des salles de bloc opératoire sont
fermés seulement 4% pour cause de covin
les autres fermeture s'explique
majoritairement par des postes vacants
au bloc les déprogrammations qui en
découlent n'ont rien à voir avec les
patients qu'ovide vacciner ou non selon
le directeur de l'ap-hp à la mi-janvier
près de 1400 postes d'infirmiers était
vacant une situation dénoncée par le
personnel soignant
aujourd'hui le qu'ovide sert d'alibi le
vrai problème c'est qu'il n'y a plus
assez de personnel essentiellement
paramédical mais parfois aussi médicale
c'est un fait on enlève des lits et on
ferme des salles car il n'y a plus de
soignants pour assurer le suivi des
interventions
certains salariés ont été suspendues car
ils n'étaient pas vaccinés mais cette
fuite des soignants s'explique avant
tout par des conditions de travail de
plus en plus difficile le métier n'est
plus attractifs les heures de travail se
rallongent et la rémunération est faible
le manque de moyens est de plus en plus
palpable dans les hôpitaux de france et
la situation semble encore loin d'un
retour à la normalité
et ce triste record à présent de la plus
longue mise en quarantaine du monde en
hommes turcs 56 ans a été testé positif
aux copines 78 fois contre ans à
l'isolément depuis 14 mois il ne peut
fréquenter et que sa femme et son fils
leur essai de mattila couvillers fleurs
noires
pour certains l'infection au kovy 19 n'a
duré que quelques jours alors que pour
d'autres cela fait des mois c'est la
triste histoire de mouz affaires callas
and un quinquagénaire turc qui a
contracté le virus en novembre 2000
vingt
neuf ashton il y a environ 14 mois j'ai
eu des symptômes tels que
l'essoufflement des nausées de la fièvre
j'ai été admis à l'hôpital ils ont fait
des tests des analyses de sang le
diagnostic c'était un qu'ovide avancés
s'ils ont pour ça qu'ils m'ont mis à
l'hôpital après ma première
hospitalisation
je suis resté à l'hôpital pendant neuf
mois
au total 78 tests réalisés tous sont
revenus positifs
la cause de cette infection sans fin les
antécédents médicaux du patient qui
avait déjà une santé fragile
j'ai des antécédents de leucémie j'ai eu
une leucémie ya quatre ans j'ai eu une
greffe de moelle osseuse il ya trois ans
je suis actuellement traités mais le
médecin dit que je ne peux pas éliminer
ce virus de mon corps parce que mon
système immunitaire est très faible et
comme les médicaments contre la leucémie
que je prends supprime le système
immunitaire je ne peux pas éliminer le
virus de mon organisme
conséquence pour le quinquagénaire un
cercle vicieux de 14 longs mois
d'isolement très affaibli mouz affaires
callas année c'est de se remettre en
forme malgré un moral fortement entamée
cela fait maintenant plus d'un an qu'il
vit à distance de sa femme et de son
fils
immunodéprimés est toujours positif au
qu'ovide le patient ne peut pas être
vaccinés les soignants lui ont récemment
administrer un traitement plus lourd
dans l'espoir de voir son état de santé
s'améliorer
à en croire à israël en accord sur le
nucléaire iranien serait est imminent
les négociations sont en cours cette
semaine les etats-unis ont fait état de
progrès substantiels
craignant pour sa sécurité l'état hébreu
dit s'attendre à un accord plus fragile
que le précédent de son côté emmanuel
macron s'est entretenu hier avec son
homologue iranien il appelle téhéran à
saisir l'opportunité de sauver l'accord
de vienne
emmanuel macron a exprimé la conviction
que les discussions menées avec la
participation active de la france et de
ses partenaires ont permis de parvenir à
une solution respectueuse des intérêts
essentiels de toutes les parties
prenantes qui permettrait d'éviter une
grave crise nucléaire
après plus de dix ans de travaux et de
controverses l'ethiopie a officiellement
lancé ce dimanche la production
d'électricité de son grand barrage de la
renaissance sur le nil projet lancé en
2011 provoquant un lourd contentieux
avec l'egypte et le soudan deux pays
tributaires du fleuve pour leurs
ressources le coût total a été estimé
par les experts à 4,2 milliards de
dollars ah ben yahmed le premier
ministre a procédé dans la journée à la
mise en route des machines affirmant que
c'est la naissance d'une ère nouvelle il
a également évoqué les rumeurs autour de
ce projet
et on de mata ou tu ailles la manette
comme vous pouvez le constater cette eau
produira de l'énergie tout en s'écoulant
comme elle le faisait auparavant vers le
soudan et l'egypte contrairement aux
rumeurs selon lesquelles le peuple et le
gouvernement éthiopien construisent des
barrages pour affaiblir l'egypte et le
soudan
l'ethiopie ne souhaite faire de mal à
personne
le seul désir de l'ethiopie et de
fournir de l'électricité aux 60%
d'éthiopiens qui en ont besoin à la mère
qui n'a jamais vu une ampoule électrique
d'alléger le fardeau de ceux qui portent
de lourdes charges sur leur dos pour
produire de l'électricité et de les
sortir de leur pauvreté actuelle
un climat toujours des plus ton du ch au
soudan avec de nouvelles manifestations
ce dimanche encore ils étaient des
milliers à protester dans les rues de
khartoum contre le coup d'état militaire
des manifestants armés de pierres
violemment repoussés par les forces de
l'ordre alors que débute la visite de
l'envoyé spécial de l'onu une personne
aurait été tuée par balles selon des
médecins 82 morts depuis le coup d'état
du général abdel fattah al burhan en
octobre
ces manifestants réclament la mise en
place d'un gouvernement civil pour
diriger la transition démocratique après
trois décennies sous la présidence
d'omar el béchir
tout d'abord nous allons rester dans les
rues et nous exigeons la remise du
pouvoir à un gouvernement entièrement
civil ensuite nous réclamons la justice
pour nos martyrs jamais nous ne ferons
de compromis et n'accepteront la
situation actuelle
la manifestation à bamako pierre après
midi a réuni plusieurs centaines de
personnes venues célébrer le départ des
troupes françaises stationnées dans le
cadre de l'opération antiterroriste
abarkan retrait annoncé par paris cette
semaine retrait précipité par des
relations très compliquées avec bamako
en un mot clair
le torchon brûle entre bamako et paris
alors que le gouvernement de transition
malien a ajourné la prochaine élection
présidentielle initialement prévue le 27
février prochain emmanuel macron appris
jeudi un virage à 90 degrés concernant
l'implication des troupes françaises
dans le pays la france et ses
partenaires engagés dans des missions de
lutte contre le terrorisme à savoir les
états participant à la task force
takouba ont pris la décision de retirer
leur présence militaire au mali nous
allons nous avons commencé à fermer des
bases au nord nous allons donc
progressivement fermés dans un exercice
qui va prendre quatre à six mois
les bases qui sont présentes au mali à
bamako l' annonce a été accueillie comme
un affront par le gouvernement de
transition en guise de riposte à la
décision d' emmanuel macron les
autorités maliennes ont exigé vendredi
le départ immédiat des forces barkan est
à kouba où le gars de ces manquements
répétés des accords de défense
gouvernement invite les autorités
françaises
allaient tirer sans délai les forces
barbares net à kouba du territoire
national sous la supervision des
autorités maliennes une exigence réfuté
dans la foulée par l'elysée qui insiste
sur le retrait progressif de l'ensemble
des troupes emmanuel macron affirme
qu'il ne transigera pas sur la sécurité
des soldats samedi une manifestation
contre la présence française et
européenne s'est déroulée à bamako les
participants n'ont pas caché leur colère
à l'encontre de paris accusé de protéger
principalement ses intérêts au détriment
de la lutte contre le djihadisme on est
sorti pour chasser la france on n'a pas
besoin de la france la france est restée
trop longtemps chez nous qu'elle s'en
aille neuf ans que la france est chez
nous tu n'as rien foutu on ne chasse
mais tu ne veux pas partir
m
[Musique]
ces fusées l'humanisme au total 2400
soldats français sont actuellement
déployés au mali à la suite de leur
départ dans les prochains mois les
troupes seront repositionnées au niger
voisin la réorganisation des forces
barkan est à kouba remettent également
en question le dispositif onusien minus
ma l'organisation des nations unies a
reconnu que ces départs auront un impact
et étudie actuellement les conséquences
de la décision française sur l'avenir de
la mission
amadou sadio barry et chercheur en
éthique des relations internationales
alors que le mali entretient des liens
diplomatiques avec la russie notamment
et ce spécialiste de l'afrique appellent
à a laissé libre bamako de discuter avec
n'importe quel pays et coûté
souveraineté va se replier quand même
des relations internationales elle
revient aux états de définir la relation
stratégique leurs orientations en
matière de politique étrangère je dire
on ne peut pas interdire au mali de
solliciter une autre puissance que la
france les puissances les grandes
puissances qui domine la scène
internationale sont en quête d'
influence par il est aussi comme la
russie comme les états unis et par
ailleurs je ne pense pas qu'il faille
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans une logique
où on
on se débarrasse on s'affranchit le pari
pour essayer de chercher un allié
stratégie alors qu'à l'intérieur de
l'état rhin nous n'avons pas défini
encore une réelle politique de
souveraineté en matière de sécurité ça
sert et une erreur il faudrait
aujourd'hui le mali les états africains
puissent se questionner sur leur
capacité à sécuriser leur territoire et
surtout la vie de la population
indépendamment de toute relation
stratégie
un retour en france zoom sur cette
enquête intitulée les infiltrés elle met
en lumière le rôle croissant des
cabinets de conseil privé dans la sphère
publique des contrats qui coûterait très
cher et ne serait pas forcément tout le
temps nécessaire c'est l'édito de katia
technique plus d'un 1,5 milliard d'euros
ont été versées par l'état aux cabinets
de conseil pour leur rapport un chiffre
astronomique qui fait scandale surtout
si on le compare avec le budget du
ministère de la culture doté de 4,2
milliards d'euros celui des outre-mer de
2,6 milliards deux journalistes de l'ops
oms publié les infiltrés il explique
comment les cabinets de conseil ont pris
le contrôle de l'état ils ont sorti la
calculatrice plus d'1 5 milliard le
chiffre est issu des estimations de
dépenses de 2019 et il est
l'aboutissement d'une constante
augmentation
c'est l'addition des expertises
demandées sur la stratégie vaccinale la
crise des masques l'approvisionnement
test mais aussi la transformation
numérique le conseil pour les achats de
l'état une commission denquête a été
mise en place dès novembre 2021 le
ministre de la santé olivier vers ans
l'ancien secrétaire d'état chargé du
numérique cedrico des représentants
d'edf de la sncf de la poste ont été
convoqués et bien sûr les nombreux
directeurs des cabinets de conseil afin
de tenter de déconstruire un nouveau
système quasi parasitaire le plus
incompréhensible c'est que l'état est
incapable de dire combien il a dépensé
en 2021 quelques chiffres ont filtré le
ministère de la santé a signé des
contrats avec sept cabinets pour gérer
la crise sanitaire pour un montant de
11,3 millions d'euros l'état a commandé
en 2020 pour 628 millions d'euros deux
conseils dont une grande part pour
l'informatique qui sont les heureux
bénéficiaires de ces contrats ces
grandes entreprises qui ne connaissent
pas la crise des cabinets de groupe
anglo saxons tels boston consulting
group accenture bas une compagnie rsta
niang ou encore pour les français web
stone et capgemini et bien sûr le
cabinet américain très connu mckinsey le
grand gagnant avec 10,7 millions touché
dans les 18 premiers mois de la crise
sanitaire d'une part pourquoi se sentir
obligés de commander des rapports alors
que les hauts fonctionnaires en place
déjà grassement rémunérés pourrait
s'atteler à ce travail il existe
l'inspection des finances l'igas la cour
des comptes ces brillants esprits ne
sont ils pas capables d'organiser un
séminaire sur l'avenir du métier
d'enseignant qui a coûté 496000 euros à
l'état ou encore un guide du télétravail
235000 620 euros prix d'ami et si les
agents publics ne sont pas capables de
délivrer des rapports pertinents et
audits efficace pourquoi ont-ils été
recrutés les journalistes de l'obs
relève qu'en effet les services de
l'état ne sont pas des acheteurs
compétent ce qui s'avère désastreux
lorsqu'un parc informatique entier doit
être renouvelé autre problème il ya un
risque à déléguer au privé et de plus à
des sociétés étrangères des pans entiers
relevant des activités de l'état que
devient notre souveraineté d'autant
qu'on s'en doute ces sociétés privées
sont missionnés pour tailler dans les
budgets ce dont elle s'acquitte par
exemple mc kinsey recommandé il y a deux
ans de diminuer de 25 % les lits
d'hôpitaux sache préconisations presque
visionnaire interrogé mercredi sur cette
gabegie le ministre olivier vers ans a
expliqué que les cabinets de conseil en
santé n'avait coûté que 25 millions sur
30 milliards de dépenses c'est tout de
même moins que ce que la france a donné
pour la recherche du vaccin contre le
coc vide avec les résultats qu'on
connaît mais il a aussi prétendu que le
transfert de patients dans des trains
médicalisé durant la crise du coc vide
avait été assurée grâce au privé or le
samu et la sncf sont les vrais
organisateurs de ces dix convois le
ministre vient de le reconnaître et de
s'excuser mais cette méprise était
intéressante car le ministre avait
précisé que ses services étaient
incapables de remplir une telle mission
face à cette tempête l'exécutif a promis
il ya un mois de baisser de 15% au moins
les dépenses en 2022 il n'y aura plus de
recours automatique à ses consultants et
les tares cherchera d'abord s'il ya des
compétences en interne pourquoi cela
n'at-il pas été la règle dès le début
mystère le porte parole du gouvernement
gabriela talent a annoncé vendredi le
développement d'un cabinet de conseil
interne après 20 audition scrupuleuses
la commission rendra ses conclusions le
19 mars et cela risque de coûter cher au
gouvernement et c'est la fin de cette
édition prochain j'étais dans une
trentaine de minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]